I sang karaoke last night so my voice is
shot in the opening scene we are
introduced to a billionaire named Richie
and his wife Hunter who are enjoying a
dinner party with other affluent
individuals the occasion is Richie's
recent accomplishments in business which
has garnered his company a lot of profit
his parents appear to be extremely proud
of him after the dinner comes to an end
Richie and Hunter retire to their new
opulent house located in Upstate New
York despite her Newfound life of luxury
Hunter who comes from a working class
background spends most of her days
feeling bored and unfulfilled she
occupies herself by cooking playing
mobile games and sketching in fact she
finds herself emotionally suppressed and
isolated because Richie is always
distant and inconsiderate towards her at
one dinner Hunter attempts to initiate a
conversation with her husband but he is
too preoccupied with work-related texts
texts to give her the attention she
craves a few days after the dinner party
Hunter discovers that she is pregnant
and shares the news with her husband who
is overjoyed the prospect of starting a
family to celebrate this momentous
occasion the couple decides to go out
for dinner with Richie's parents during
the meal Hunter wants to tell one of her
childhood stories but her father-in-law
abruptly interrupts her and starts
talking about business matters feeling
disheartened Hunter Retreats into
herself and begins staring at the
glistening ice cubes in her glass as her
mood darkens she impulsively takes one
of the cubes into her mouth and begins
biting down on it causing discomfort and
awkwardness among the other diners the
next day Hunter's mother-in-law
Catherine enters her room and hands her
a gift about postpartum depression
sharing that it helped her during her
own pregnancy Catherine also takes the
opportunity to comment on Hunter's
appearance suggesting that she would
look more beautiful with longer hair as
Richie prefers women with longer locks
later while reading the same book Hunter
comes across a passage that inspires her
to do something unexpected in a moment
of Reckless abandon she reaches for a
small marble from her Trinkets and
swallows it whole surprisingly this
makes her feel a lot better marbles are
the new keto Upon returning home from
work Richie is surprised to find his
wife in a good mood he questions the
reason behind her happiness to which she
responds that she did something
unexpected that made her proud of
herself however when Richie inquires
further about what it was Hunter lies
and says that it was merely a decision
to choose blue curtains the following
morning as Richie prepares for work he
becomes upset with Hunter after
discovering that she has ruined one of
his silk ties later that day Hunter is
able to pass the small marble she had
swallowed earlier grabbing it from the
sink without any signs of disgust
shortly after she is summoned by her
mother-in-law for a conversation during
which Catherine inquires about hunter's
previous employment before marrying
Richie Hunter admits stabbing Works in
retail specifically selling toiletries
hearing this Catherine mentions that
Hunter is a very lucky woman as she got
the chance to marry Richie she also
questions whether Hunter is truly happy
or simply putting on a facade the latter
insists that she is indeed happy despite
her Impressions suggesting otherwise one
day while cleaning the house Hunter
comes across a tempting object a
thumbtack which she decides to swallow
despite her initial hesitation Hunter
eventually puts the Thumbtack in her
mouth only to have her tongue poked she
tries to resist the urge to swallow it
but eventually succumbs to the impulse
and ingests the object feeling a sense
of relief that same evening Richie
returns home with some friends in tow
Hunter intends to greet them at the pool
but the pain caused by the Thumbtack
suddenly intensifies prompting her to
rush to the bathroom she excretes the
Thumbtack but the ensuing struggle
leaves a lot of blood on the toilet seat
fortunately before Richie can find out
about it Hunter quickly cleans it up and
exits the bathroom at the pool one of
Richie's friends congratulates Hunter on
her pregnancy however things take a
strange turn when he asks for a hug
claiming that he is feeling lonely
Hunter reluctantly agrees to the hug but
it becomes apparent that she needed the
hug more than he did as time passes
Hunter becomes increasingly drawn to
consuming no non-edible items that she
finds lying around her home including
metal figurines batteries book pages
safety pins and various other objects it
seems as if the thrill of eating these
items is incredibly exhilarating for her
and she is unable to resist the
temptation to do so one day during her
routine ultrasound appointment the
sonogram technician detects an
abnormality in Hunter's abdomen she is
quickly rushed in for emergency surgery
where the surgeon discovers a plethora
of inedible objects that had been
trapped in her intestine after a
thorough examination the doctor
diagnosis Hunter with pika pika a
psychological disorder that compels
individuals to eat non-food items Upon
returning home Richie is understandably
angry and confused wondering what could
possibly be wrong with her Hunter claims
that she does not know what is happening
to her and has never even heard of Pika
before
concern for his wife's well-being Richie
and his parents decide to arrange for
Hunter to see a psychiatrist in the city
initially they insist on being present
during her sessions and so the
psychiatrist Alice requests to speak
with Hunter alone during their private
conversation Alice asks Hunter how it
makes her feel to swallow these objects
and the latter reveals that she enjoys
the feel of their Textures in her mouth
furthermore Richie hires a Syrian man
named Louie to keep a closer eye on his
wife while he is at work unfortunately
this only serves to frustrate Hunter
further over the next several days
Hunter becomes increasingly irritated
with Louie's attempts to assist her in
the kitchen he begins to criticize her
mental health issues insinuating that if
she had gone through what he had in
Syria she would not have such problems
furthermore he even inspects her before
allowing her to use the bathroom however
despite all this the obsessed Hunter
still finds a way to swallow non-food
items as a form of satisfaction the
scene then shifts to Richie's birthday
celebration a lavish party at their
mansion during the party Hunter
discovers that everyone in attendance is
aware of her swallowing problem she can
Richie asking why he told everyone but
he dismisses her claiming that it is his
special day and he does not want her to
ruin it this leaves Hunter feeling hurt
and upset later that night as the couple
is having coitus Hunter abruptly stops
and demands that Richie apologized
before they can continue during her next
therapy session Hunter shares a deeply
personal and traumatic experience she
reveals that she was not raised by her
biological father and has never met him
but she keeps a picture of him Hunter
also disguises that she was actually
conceived after her mom was forced upon
by a stranger one day while in the
garden Hunter becomes fixated on the
soil but manages to resist the urge to
consume it however while washing her
hands she overhears her husband talking
to her therapist on the phone Hunter
realizes that Richie has bribed the
therapist to reveal what they discussed
during her sessions Alice divulges all
the information about her last session
with Hunter including her mother's case
this sends Hunter into a state of panic
as soon as Richie leaves for work she
breaks down in tears a short while later
luway walks into the room to check on
Hunter only to discover her under the
bed feeling bad he joins her there and
gently Pats her shoulder providing a
source of comfort and support during
this difficult time in the dead of night
Hunter wakes up from her sleep and
notices Louie lying soundly beside her
her compulsion to swallow inanimate
objects once again Rises so she starts
scouring the drawers frantically when
nothing comes in sight she hastily picks
up a screwdriver and swallows it however
this turns out to be a bad decision as
Hunter starts choking prompting Louie to
wake up from his sleep he immediately
dials 9-1-1 and rushes her to the
hospital fortunately the surgeons are
able to extract the swallowed item from
her body without harming hunter or the
fetus that baby is going to grow up to
become shoe nice following this
frightening ordeal Hunter finds herself
under pressure as Richie and his parents
coerce her to sign papers committing her
to a psychiatric hospital for seven
months until she delivers the baby
although Hunter initially resists her
husband blackmails her by threatening to
divorce her if she refuses this leaves
her with no other option but to comply
much to the sympathy of Louis who is
observing everything from nearby the
following day Hunter packs her
belongings and prepares to leave for the
psychiatric hospital but at the last
second she returns to a room claiming to
have forgotten her charger surprisingly
Louis meets her inside and encourages
her to run through the woods Hunter
obliges and once she's out of sight
Louis stages her disappearance as an
escape I mean it was Hunter manages to
hitchhike to a motel and before entering
she Pockets some soil later she calls
her husband and confesses that she only
got pregnant to make him happy and that
they rushed into things too quickly
Richie speak kindly to her trying to
convince her to come back but when she
refuses he begins to belittle and insult
her stating that she is good for nothing
and not skilled at a single thing that's
not true Richie I eat
after the Collins Hunter crushes her
cell phone and spends the rest of the
night alone watching TV and eating soil
the following day Hunter checks out of
her motel room and proceeds to call her
mother to ask if she can stay with her
unfortunately the latter declines
stating that her other daughter is
currently residing with her finding
herself without a place to go hunter
decides to hitchhike to the home of her
biological father William Irwin upon
reaching his house she discovers that
William is celebrating his birthday with
his family and friends Hunter goes close
to him but William assumes that she is
the parent of one of their daughter's
friends hunter clarifies that she is not
a parent and mentions her mother's name
hearing this William immediately
recognizes her as his estranged daughter
after getting a chance to talk alone
Hunter proceeds to question why he took
advantage of her mother and William
admits that he felt powerful when he
committed such acts however after
serving several years in jail he
realizes his mistakes and regrets them
the conversation becomes emotional as
William expresses his shame and guilt
for his past actions Hunter inquires if
he feels shame towards her and whether
she is like him William immediately
refutes these claims assuring hunter
that she is not akin to him and bears no
responsibility for the past events as
Hunter's emotions overwhelm her William
offers consolation and reminds her that
she is blameless and should not carry
the burden of guilt after finding solace
in her emotional conversation with
William Hunter feels ready to move
forward with her life she makes the
difficult decision to undergo on
abortion and visits a clinic where she
has prescribed medication for the
procedure Hunter takes the pills while
eating lunch in a food court and despite
the bustling surroundings she
experiences the physical effects of the
abortion in a public restroom alone with
her thoughts once the procedure is
complete Hunter feels a sense of
Liberation and relief wash over her she
recognizes that this decision was not an
easy one but it was the right one for
her at this moment in her life with
Newfound freedom and a clear Head Hunter
sets out to embark on a fresh start
leaving the pain and Trauma of her past
behind she will now head to the Toys R
Us and eat some Beyblades
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching